In problem number one, 3x equals 12. x is not by itself yet because it's being
multiplied by 3. The thing that undoes multiplication is division. So you need
to divide by the number we're presently multiplying. So, I'm going to say we
need to divide this entire side by 3. Now, whatever we do over here, we also
need to do on the right side. Divide 12 by 3 as well. We know that 3x over 3
gives us just x, which is why we wanted to divide by 3 in the first place. So
now, we need to carry it out on the right hand side. 12 over 3 is 4. So we get x
equals 4. Checking our answer, we have 3 times 4 equals 12, and 3 times 4 does
in fact equal 12. So we're in good shape. And number two, x is being divided by
3. In the last problem we undid multiplication with division. So here, we can
undo division with multiplication. To undo division by 3, we need to multiply by
that same number 3. You do this to both sides and 12 times 3 is 36. Checking, 36
over 3 is in fact equal to 12. Awesome.
Another one done. Last but not least, x minus 3 equals 12. This problem is
telling us that we're looking for a number so that if we took 3 away from that
number, we would get 12. That means that number is 3 greater than 12 then. So,
to undo this subtraction on the left hand side, we need to add 3. And over here,
we get x equals 15. We will also confirm that 15 minus 3 equals 12. Great.